yahar after killing me what did you plan
on doing next
you know you don't have to lean into the
whole pirate thing can he attack
what the hell you're 43 years old you
best start believing in good stories mr
rogers
you're in one see it goes right through
me and that's the result of a healthy
pliable life
i can't believe brady took down all
three of us legends
another uneventful season look if you
think that you can just waltz in
okay never mind you always remember the
day you almost caught pet him
home let's go no i want it to hurt
he could never love me like a number one
receiver i'm just a lowly tight end
dang britney still has a cannon there
once was a team twas lost at sea
to there came a man named tom brady
ditched winston they began to win
throw less picks tom throw soon may
the buccaneers
and you're sure young people like this
seashell is hot now better not be
messing with me i do not want to look
old
who are you rooting for i just watched
for the commercials then welcome to team
state farm
[Music]
er come on that's dpi parlay okay so i'm
going with evans under 60 yards and got
one another 70.
excuse me you get all we'll never catch
them they're pirate
at the football field we named the
monkey gronk
curse you tom you'll never get away with
going to a team with an already great
offense
i started the season on the chest it's
me
controversial third receivers scotty
miller who the hell is that dude you're
clearly julian edelman in disguise but
no why did tom say something ah
don't chase us or i'll throw y'all in
ronald jones locker
sub the enemies in charge of the ship
mean
finally if i win without belichick i'll
be free of the curse of the system qv
look they gave me a sword you me
oh god did i kill patrick mahomes i
could probably get away with this
don't you see i'm the new main football
character this is my legacy i'm only 25.
you know there's 52 other players on the
team right
52. wait do you just think any number's
funny
[Music]
wow tom you made it without me
i'm actually so proud of you
come come here son
now it's safe let's hug it out